>>> THIS IS CNN BREAKING NEWS.
>>> IT'S THE TOP OF THE HOUR ON
"CNN NEWSROOM," I'M ALISYN
CAMEROTA.
>> I'M VICTOR BLACKWELL.
WE BEGIN WITH BREAKING NEWS, CNN
HAS LEARNED THAT RUSSIA
RESPONDED TO THE PRISONER SWAP
OFFER FOR THE RELEASE OF TWO
AMERICANS IN RUSSIAN PRISONS.
SOURCES SAY NOW THAT RUSSIA
REQUESTED A COLONEL CONVICTED OF
MURDER AND ADDED ALONG THIS
INFAMOUS ARMS DEALER FOR WNBA
STAR BRITTNEY GRINER AND PAUL
WHELAN.
>> WE HAVE A TEAM OF
CORRESPONDENTS COVERING THESE
BREAKING DEVELOPMENTS.
FREDERIK PLEITGEN IS IN MOSCOW
FOR US.
LET'S START WITH NATASHA
BERTRAND, WHO IS BREAKING THIS
EXCLUSIVE.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED.
>> Reporter: WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
IS THAT IN RESPONSE TO THE
RUSSIAN PROPOSAL TO TRADE THAT
ARMS DEALER, VIKTOR BOUT FOR THE
TWO AMERICANS DETAINED IN
RUSSIA, PAUL WHELAN AND BRITTNEY
GRINER, THE RUSSIANS PUT FORWARD
THEIR OWN REQUEST AND THEY SAID
WE DON'T WANT JUST VIKTOR BOUT,
WE WANT THIS GUY NAME VADIM KRZ
KROSOKOV, CONVICTED IN DECEMBER
OF 2021 FOR MURDERING IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT A CHECH AN FIGHTER AND
THE GERMANS SENTENCED HIM TO
LIFE IN PRISON.
THE RUSSIANS IN RESPONSE TO THIS
PROPOSAL SUBMITTED THIS KIND OF
BACK CHANNEL REQUEST TO THE
AMERICANS.
IT WAS DONE THROUGH AN FSB BACK
CHANNEL, THE FSB OF COURSE IS
THE MAIN SECURITY SERVICE FOR
THE RUSSIANS.
AND THROUGH THIS BACK CHANNEL IT
WAS VERY INFORMAL.
THEY SAID THAT THEY WANTED THIS
PERSON TO BE INCLUDED IN THE
SWAP ALONG WITH VIKTOR BOUT.
NOW, THE U.S. DID NOT TAKE THIS
REQUEST VERY SERIOUSLY.
IT WAS VERY PROBLEMATIC FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS.
CHIEF AMONG THEM IS THAT THIS
GUY IS STILL IN GERMAN CUSTODY,
SO THE UNITED STATES WOULD IN
FACT HAVE TO USE ITS INFLUENCE
TO GET HIM RELEASED FROM GERMAN
CUSTODY TO INCLUDE HIM IN THE
PRISONER SWAP.
OTHER THAN THAT, IT WAS NOT
VIEWED BY THE U.S. TO BE A
SERIOUS COUNTER PROPOSAL TO WHAT
THE U.S. HAD SAID IS A VERY
SUBSTANTIATIVE PROPOSAL, WHICH
IS TO TRADE BOUT FOR THESE TWO
AMERICANS.
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN WHETHER
THE RUSSIANS HAVE PUT FORWARD OR
WILL PUT FORWARD ANY OTHER
REQUESTS.
THIS SHOWS, THIS UNDERSCORES
THAT THE RUSSIANS DID, IN FACT,
ENGAGE WITH THE U.S.'S PROPOSAL.
NOW, WHETHER OR NOT THE
AMERICANS VIEW THAT AS
SUBSTANTIATIVE, THAT'S ANOTHER
QUESTION.
>> FRED, YOU'RE SHARING THE
BYLINE ON THIS EXCLUSIVE
REPORTING.
THE U.S. SAYS THAT IT'S NOT A
SERIOUS PROPOSAL.
HAS IT EVEN GONE FAR ENOUGH THAT
GERMANY HAS RESPONDED?
>> THE GERMANS CERTAINLY DID AT
LEAST DEAL WITH IT TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
SHOWS JUST HOW SERIOUS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ABOUT TRYING
TO GET THE PRISONER SWAP TO
HAPPEN, TO GET BRITTNEY GRINER
AND PAUL WHELAN OUT OF RUSSIAN
CUSTODY, THERE WERE QUIET
INQUIRIES BY THE U.S. TO THE
GERMAN GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE THAT FROM A SENIOR
GERMAN GOVERNMENT SOURCE SAYING
THIS WAS ON A LOW LEVEL AND THE
GERMANS NEVER REALLY BELIEVED
THAT IT WAS A REAL STRONG
PROPOSAL OR ONE TO BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY.
IT WAS MERELY AN INQUIRY, WOULD
THE GERMANS BE WILLING TO
CONSIDER THAT.
THE GERMANS SAY THAT THEY NEVER
REALLY TALKED ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL ON A HIGHER LEVEL, AND
NEVER REACHED THE TOP LEVELS OF
GERMAN GOVERNMENT, BUT CERTAINLY
THEY DID RECEIVE INQUIRIES FROM
THE U.S. ABOUT KROSOKOV,
HOWEVER, HE IS AN IMPORTANT
PRISONER TO THE GERMANS.
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WASN'T
BROADLY DISCUSSED IN THE
GOVERNMENT, THE U.S. DID MAKE
THAT INQUIRY.
>> TELL US ABOUT WHY HE IS SO
IMPORTANT.
HE WAS A COLONEL AND WHAT ELSE?
>> WELL, HE WAS A COLONEL IN THE
FSB, THE INTELLIGENCE SERVICE OT
RUSSIANS, AND HE'S OBVIOUSLY THE
ONE THE GERMAN COURT CONVICTED
OF KILLING THAT FORMER
CHECHNYAEN FIGHTER IN BROAD
DAYLIGHT IN 2019.
THE REASON THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
FOR THE GERMANS IS THE COURT IN
GERMANY THAT DEALT WITH THIS
CASE CLEARLY STATED THAT THIS
WAS A MURDER THAT WAS CALLED FOR
BY THE RUSSIAN FEDERATION THAT
WAS ORGANIZED BY RUSSIA'S STATE
SECURITY SERVICES AND
ESSENTIALLY LED BY RUSSIA STATE
SECURITY SERVICE.
IT CAUSED A HUGE SPAT BETWEEN
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT AND THE
GERMAN GOVERNMENT.
SEVERAL RUSSIAN DIPLOMATS WERE
EXPELLED, AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IS NOT
ONLY THAT THE GERMANS SAID,
LOOK, THIS IS A COMPLETE BREACH
OF GERMAN SOVEREIGNTY, AND JUST
FOR THAT REASON, A VERY
IMPORTANT PRISONER TO THE
GERMANS BUT ALSO HAPPENED RIGHT
AFTER A CHANGE OF GOVERNMENT IN
GERMANY AS WELL.
IT WAS WHEN ANGELA MERKEL LEFT
OFFICE, THE CONVICTION WAS AFTER
ANGELA MERKEL LEFT OFFICE AND
THE SCHULTZ GOVERNMENT CAME INTO
OFFICE.
RIGHT AFTER THAT IS WHEN THE
CONVICTION HAPPENED AND THE NEW
GERMAN GOVERNMENT SHOWED
IMMEDIATELY EXPELLED RUSSIAN
DIPLOMATS.
CROSOKOV IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PRISONER THAT THE GERMANS ARE
HOLDING AND THERE'S NO
CONSIDERATIONS I'M TOLD RIGHT
NOW IN BERLIN TO RELEASE
KROSOKOV.
>> NATASHA, U.S. SECRETARY OF
STATE TONY BLINKEN SPOKE WITH
HIS RUSSIAN COUNTER PART TODAY
BUT THIS WAS NOT THE VEHICLE FOR
THAT OFFER.
HOW DID THE RUSSIANS RESPOND AND
ASK FOR THIS ADDITIONAL TRADE?
>> CORRECT, VICTOR, AND WHAT
WE'RE TOLD IS THE RUSSIANS
COMMUNICATED THIS THROUGH A BACK
CHANNEL.
ESSENTIALLY FSB OFFICERS REACHED
OUT TO THE UNITED STATES THROUGH
THESE CHANNELS TO FLOAT THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THEY WOULD
POTENTIALLY GET KROSOKOV BACK.
THEY TOLD THE UNITED STATES, IF
YOU'RE OFFERING BOUT, WE WANT
KROSOKOV.
THIS WAS NOT VIEWED BY THE U.S.
AS A SERIOUS PROPOSAL.
IT WAS IT WAS NOT PROPOSED AT
THE LAVROV BLINKEN LEVEL.
IT WAS PROPOSED AT LOWER
LEVELINGS.
IT GAVE THE IDEA OF THE SWAP
RUSSIA MIGHT BE LOOKING FOR AND
SAID INDICATED TO THE UNITED
STATES THAT RUSSIA MIGHT NOT BE
SERIOUS ABOUT THE SWAP AT ALL
BECAUSE IT WAS JUST NOT VIEWED
AS SOMETHING THE U.S. AND
GERMANY WOULD ACTUALLY BE
WILLING TO DO.
IT WAS VIEWED MORE BY THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT AS AN ATTEMPT TO BUY
TIME, AS AN ATTEMPT TO STALL
UNTIL THE TRIAL OF BRITTNEY
GRINER IS OVER, AND THEN THE
RUSSIANS FEEL THEY CAN COME TO
THE TABLE.
SO ALL OF THIS WAS VIEWED BY THE
UNITED STATES REALLY AS A GAME
THAT THE RUSSIANS WERE PLAYING.
THEY DON'T VIEW IT AS SERIOUS.
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN OF COURSE
WHETHER THE RUSSIANS ARE GOING
TO ASK FOR ANOTHER PERSON IN
ADDITION TO BOUT ON A MORE
FORMAL LEVEL BECAUSE OF COURSE
THE U.S. IS ASKI